étranger
[Musique]
merci
étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
alerte [
Sky rafaeli celegito euh, elle
l'avait littéralement rencontré sept jours avant que ce
crime ne se produise et c'était une grosse
tête de hasch donc il y avait un  beaucoup de hash fumé
et ils étaient défoncés tout le temps
c'est
[Musique] [
Musique]
tapis de bain dans la salle de bain personne n'était
là et elle elle avait pris une douche et
puis elle était retournée voir Raphaël euh
pendant que j'en parlais elle  J'ai pensé que c'était
un peu inhabituel et ils ont essayé d'appeler
Meredith,
puis ils ont appelé la police et quand la
police est arrivée et ils ont enfoncé la
porte de la chambre de Meredith et c'est là qu'ils
ont découvert le corps d'
Amanda Knox avait euh 20
ans, elle venait d'un appartement cassé.  à la maison à
Seattle et agissant d'une manière qui
disons que les filles italiennes de cet âge ne
connaissent pas les drogues sexuelles
euh tu sais faire des exercices de yoga au
poste de police après que euh la colocataire
a été assassinée, elle a rapidement attiré l'
attention du procureur la raison
qu'Amanda Knox était effrayée
était uniquement sur la base des théories
du procureur local McNamee,
tout le monde était le premier, puis après cela, il
s'agissait d'eux essayant de trouver n'importe quel
élément de preuve qui entrerait ensuite
en jeu et
il a dit que  le corps Le corps de Meredith
avait été recouvert d'une couette comme il me l'a
dit quand je l'ai interviewé, c'était
très clair pour lui, il a dit que la
femme devait être impliquée car
seule une femme couvrirait le corps d'
une autre femme qui est
étrangère
[Musique  ]
cas, c'est devenu comme un match de football ou
quelque chose comme les trois intérêts nationaux
et c'est devenu sexualisé, c'est
devenu un cirque de spéculation, son
surnom était Foxy Knox Evil, c'était
totalement déplaisant, cela n'avait rien à voir
avec la mort de Meredith Kircher, cela
n'avait rien à voir.  faire avec la recherche de
la justice Patrick
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
remix
ES
est
[Musique]
c'était un procès pour sorcières et le procureur
était un homme très très religieux comme un
religieux hardcore l'accent a immédiatement
été mis sur cette femme photogénique  et dont la
présence sur la scène du crime a immédiatement
provoqué les superstitions traditionnelles de ce procureur,
alors je me suis rendu à Pérouse et je
l'ai interviewé, mais il m'a
immédiatement semblé comme quelqu'un qui n'était pas
intéressé par la raison et la logique et qui ne
suivait pas les preuves si j'avais juste le
sentiment de quelqu'un qui  a été détaché
de la réalité, les procureurs ont déclaré que l'ADN de Knox
avait été trouvé sur le manche du couteau tandis que l'
ADN de la victime avait été trouvé sur la lame.
Le couteau avait été trouvé chez Rafael
où Amanda a passé beaucoup de temps, donc
évidemment, il y aurait ses empreintes digitales
dessus et l'ADN qui était  trouvé sur la
lame était si rare et peu fiable qu'il n'y
a aucune preuve disant que c'était l'
ADN de Meredith, mais surtout,
le couteau était trop gros, il ne correspondait pas
aux blessures qu'elle avait sur la
cellule du corps,
mais vous pouvez  voir des images images vidéo de
diverses personnes de différents éléments
des autorités italiennes entrant
sur la scène du crime, il y a une
séquence vidéo d'eux et il s'agit simplement de briser
la vitre de la porte et de lui donner des coups de pied
pour essayer d'entrer,
d'accord,
ce n'est pas le cas  un professionnalisme léger
que vous imagineriez voir dans d'autres
endroits, il était clair que
tout était contaminé, donc tout
ce qu'ils avaient collecté sur cette
scène de crime était d'une très très petite utilité, à part
une empreinte sanglante qui
correspondait entièrement à la taille et aux chaussures qui étaient
porté par de très bons
mois avant les meurtriers l'été
avant les meurtres, il faisait en fait des
cambriolages à domicile,
euh, vide ce qu'il pensait être des
bureaux et des maisons vides lors de sa première
conversation qu'ils ont enregistrée. Rudy, bonne
journée, dit qu'Amanda n'a rien à voir avec
ça
dès qu'il est revenu à Paris, il a
commencé à la mettre là-bas, ouais
[Musique]
tu n'as pas besoin d'être
diplômé en droit pour comprendre ce qui se passait là-
bas
quand ils ont compris qu'il était
impliqué, ils n'ont pas fait demi-tour
ils ont juste continué et ils l'
ont fait parce qu'il y avait 20 camions de télévision sur
la Piazza et ils ne pouvaient pas se lever
devant eux et dire que nous avions fait une énorme
erreur ici
[Musique]
original [
Musique]
J'aime la stéréo jusqu'au tribunal en
couleur  manifestation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je pense que si vous retourniez en Italie
maintenant, vous pourriez demander à n'importe qui. Je dirai que oui,
c'est une tueuse, ils l'ont fait sortir. Nous
demandons maintenant respectueusement à
Amanda et au reste de notre famille notre
vie privée dont nous avons besoin.  remets-toi de
cette horrible épreuve merci nous avons
été presque oubliés dans
les médias les photos ne sont pas vraiment d'elle
euh il n'y a pas grand chose sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé au début
euh donc c'est très difficile de
garder sa mémoire vivante
[Musique  ]
définitivement
étrangère
euh
sporka est putana
appelée contrario
Republica
PDG le consommateur
[Musique]